الى التطورات الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
حيث قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان جنديا
روسيا قتل جراء هجوم اوكراني بصواريخ
مجنحه على مقر اسطول البحر الاسود في
سباستو بشبه جزيره القرن وقد اعلن الجيش
الاوكراني انه نجح في استهداف مقر قياده
البحريه الروسيه في البحر الاسود التطورات
وجديد وبيانات وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
نتابعها مع من موسكو مع الجزيره سامر يوسف
ومن الجانب الاوكراني معنا من زبروجيا
مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام ابدا بك سامر
اذا وما تقوله المعطيات العسكريه الروسيه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بدايه عثمان تتحدث
عن العمليات الميدانيه ايضا عن مقتل نحو
500 جندي اوكراني على محاور متعدده من
اخرسون ودونيت
ومناطق اخرى من البلدات المحيطه بهذه
المقاطعتين
وصدها هجمات للتقدم بمحور للقوات
الاوكرانيه وتدمير رادارات وطائرات مسيره
وهجمات صاروخيه ايضا تم صدها من قبل
الدفاعات الروسيه هناك ولكن يبقى الحدث
الاهم هذا اليوم هو الهجوم الاوكراني على
شبه جزيره القرم الاوضاع حاليا تبدو هادئه
بعد هذا الهجوم هناك دعوات مستمره
للمدنيين للبقاء في اماكن امنه وعدم
التوجه الى مركز المدينه عمليا يقرا من
خلال البيانات الروسيه بان الهجوم لم يكن
كبيرا ولكن معنويا هناك تاثير بطبيعه
الحال على اعتبار ان القوات الاوكرانيه
سلاح الجو الاوكراني تمكن من جديد ان صح
القول من الوصول الى الاسطول البحري هناك
والى مناطق حساسه في شبه جزيره القرم
يتوقع بان لا تنتهي هذه الهجمات ولكن يبقى
الوضع تحت السيطره الان بحسب
السلطات الروسيه هناك في سباس وماذا عن
الجانب
الاوكراني الياس
عثمان القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه اعترفت
بشكل رسمي بمسؤوليتها عن توجيه هذا الهجوم
ولكن لم تدلي بكثير من التفاصيل حول
طبيعته بمعنى هل استخدمت فيه المقاتلات
الحربيه ام كان ذلك اطلاقا لصواريخ مجنحه
بعيده المدى لكن واضح بان القياده
العسكريه في اوكرانيا وكذلك السياسيه لم
تعد تخفي سرا تلك الضربات التي توجهها
للمقر العسكريه والقواعد العسكريه الروسيه
في القرن وذلك ربما يكون يحمل ايضا رساله
الى الخارج الى حلفاء اوكرانيا هذه
الرساله تقول بانه رغم ان الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني البطيء على كافه جبهات القتال
الا ان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه ما زالت
قادره على توجيه ضربات مؤلمه وموجعه
واستراتيجيه وربما معنو
للقوات الروسيه تحديدا في القرن هذا من
ناحيه او من ناحيه اخرى هي ايضا رساله
للحلفاء بضروره تزويد كيف كما تطلب
بالصواريخ بعيده المدى سواء كان الامريكيه
منها او الالمانيه
وذلك ان اوكرانيا وعدت الخلفاء بانه اذا
ما زودت بهذه الصواريخ فهي سوف تستخدمها
فقط في الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي تحتلها
روسيا ولن تستخدمها ضد القواعد العسكريه
الروسيه في الاتحاد الروسي من ناحيه اخرى
هذا الهجوم اليوم يضاف الى هجمات
استراتيجيه ونوعيه اخرى كانت البحريه
الاوكرانيه قد نفذتها في الاسابيع الماضيه
نشير الى ان البحريه الاوكرانيه قالت
بانها تمكنت من الاستيلاء على منصات الغاز
في البحر الاسود هذه المنصات التي سيطرت
عليها روسيا مع بدايه الحرب واستخدمتها
منصات
لتزويد الطائرات العموديه بالصواريخ وكذلك
قيام البحريه الاوكرانيه بتوجيه ضربات
لسفينه حربيه وغواصه روسيه في
القرم هذا بالاضافه الى ما كانت اعلنته
المخابرات
الاوكرانيه بالامس عن توجيه ضربه عسكريه
لمطار ساكي العسكري في القرم وقبل قليل
نشرت وسائل اعلام اوكرانيه بما فيها
القناه الرابعه والعشرين ما قالت انها صور
لاقمار اصطناعيه تظهر وجود طائرات حربيه
مقاتله روسيه في هذا المطار واختفاء هذه
المقاتلات بعد توجيه الضربه العسكريه لهذا
المطار بالامس اذا هذا هذه التطورات تحمل
اضافه الى الرسائل العسكريه ايضا كما قلنا
رسائل سياسيه لحلفاء شكرا جزيلا من الياس
كرام وشكرا من موسكو سامر يوسف